back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
oh I remember this one girl I met one
time in when was that third grade
no no no she went to school when I was
an adult man and she had these breasts
that felt like
damn [ __ ] diapers you know what I'm
talking about [ __ ] diapers yeah like
baggy well they almost like you could
mold them and they would stay that well
like memory foam too yeah yeah it's
pretty cool but warm but they were warm
cuz they're attached to her human body
the human body parts kiss well sometimes
when they're fake they're cold oh yeah
that's the worst man that's the worst I
knew a girl who had a cold something one
of the the solution they put in to hurt
it was kind of cold it was like a um I
don't know it might have had a little
bit of mercury in it or somebody who was
a little bit lower than body temperature
she had that friggin cold tought off to
one side
dude I was running the other day and
there was just this girl had him it was
like two camel packs you know I can sip
out of it just she could sip on it just
like this oh dang yeah with those
Italian nipples brother just nature's
but I had the tubes oh yeah i'ma tell
him nipples bro I'm just saying there's
Italian girls man they're really you
know they'll get there before they get
their brother nipples of beauty around
two nipples no but they have nipples
that are like four inches long and
they'll be out in front like a sweet
potato baby really yeah man hey are you
excited yeah again no yeah brother are
you excited to go to your first UFC this
week I've been training at the house
dude doing tiger rolls in the yard
I'll be back strap it up when you go I
would shave your head I was I meant to
tell you that I think they're gonna pick
on you uh oh you think I would shave
your head just so you fit in cuz you're
gonna stick out I don't want you get
bullied
while we're I had or something good idea
we're yeah we're I had like a scarf you
ruin hard for your boy doesn't worry
Woori a do the diamond diamond cutter
Holloway's about to get [ __ ] cut son
yeah Holloway's that fools go baby you
don't [ __ ] with the diamond though for
sure you want to bet on it you got that
Holloway's that Cowboys are calling him
boy you guys about to get [ __ ] sold
at the mall for a couple ji-sun all the
ways the straight up he is man I was on
my side Oshin killer
dude it's just so like every it's just
yeah you can fight yeah you want to bet
on it
oh your poor yeas boy you guys from the
same hometown yeah same home school what
uh I'll bet we want a bad bro Olay know
I love Dustin Poirier this is just a
symbiote yes black and white does you
know I love you and your wife both of
them are white I think Holloway could be
Latino these definitely Hawaiian by here
is he really he's flying
yeah from all you bro yeah but Hawaii
Hawaii what does it do that's basically
Western Latinos the Mexicans of the
island yeah yes they call it some people
call them water Mexicans so apologize
for my races friend I'm sorry
and I I also you might be right I like
Hawaii hmm a lot of good people over
there okay so what do you talk to shave
ice as we call oh yeah yeah well there's
a lot more to them than just some
product they make you know they're an
indigenous people they come from long
histories of Native American culture
Hakuna Matata yeah that's what I'm
saying
yeah bro so what you wanna bet I don't
know what are you doing I think you
already have an idea no I don't money's
not that fun is it you make it I can't
afford a better yet you're out your
goddamn mind you could bet dude you have
money dude give me money tattoo on your
arm you have money you have money so
like 19 shows in San Jose yeah but not
at that good of deals man you said
you've been making the money man come on
what do you want to bet uh I'm gonna bet
a grand
a grand grant that's crazy man is it but
it's at least we have cheddar in the
game and no sortie I'll do 40 $40 yeah
I'd really just kick me in the nuts not
fun what do you mean it's not fun you
ready dogs not fun put your money where
your mouth is dude yeah okay let's do a
grand oh I'll do I'll do how about this
how about if because he mm-hmm
come on man I'm gonna kick to the nuts
he already said that no I'm saying
whoever loses gets kicked out on the not
our man yeah that's not fun yeah then
what if something happens to one of us
when we get hurt and I know then you
can't have kids anymore
yeah which I I don't think I can have
you don't think you can have them I
don't think so I think I mean I haven't
seen look like a stay-at-home dad
really yeah you dress like one oh thanks
dude just without the kids yeah I got
this new shirt actually well I sure know
g-star wrong it's nice dude I dig it man
you're making Bank now what could we bet
if you don't want a better grant fund oh
five hundo no guy what are you talking
about I'll bet you $50 I went up to 50
so either accept it or don't let's start
the frickin show you doing hundred huh
hundred dollars no Holly
you look like a guy that plays [ __ ]
sixta bass right now well [ __ ] New
Jersey is that your where she's staying
babe it is yeah you see the back of that
hit Oh Joel oh you're going to jail bro
I like that first team off first league
softball baby Wow look I straight flex
acun right now bro you're Fergus way
like [ __ ] Manny Ramirez oh yeah
[ __ ] repair put yours on so you look
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] Ryan
Sandberg you look like rhinestones
Sandberg sexiest guy that comes to fix
kill cranes that are broken at
restaurant oh you'd like the backup
quarterback of a ball blind hey let's
start you are hey Bo I'll say this man
you know John Mike
I don't every time a Pepsi truck a
delivery truck stops you're the guy that
gets out of them the driver dude yeah
you're like I'm just doing this is a
side job till I open up my gym that's
you you're every dude that's about to
open up a gym bro okay you go like this
you look like the third Nick Diaz
brother but with downside they call me
not Diaz I'm not Diaz
all right let's do this man I start with
a king in the state yeah that's our boy
posted on the MS ike dirty derrick
postings in here today man we call that
the dirty dirty posting up in this [ __ ]
we call that the ethnic corner let's see
I think quarters Chen's in the corner
you got Derek who is a mix gentleman no
that gentleman right hey you think you
did on the black-and-white it makes a
gentleman bro sorry mixed gentleman and
chin is will do knows he's not mixed
from the folks with with [ __ ]
evilness in Korean is he really yeah I
see the Lord it is that Han they call so
Han I always got the Han yeah you can
only get that Korean barbecue uh you
want yeah we got our first mission from
Matthew Moore Matt Moore what up do what
a Brendan maybe a punching the other
thing it
Danny single moms' I would do it but
daddy gonna have to be the Lord fill me
what you think game oh my god what's
going on here
is that on the set of [ __ ] making bad
dude is this at a chief keef up social
media meeting this was insane we watch
that one working why is one half a black
guy broke one has a one is fully black
the other guy in a suit and then once
just one black guy he's just trying to
[ __ ] say and that's in Seattle they're
cooking up something
yeah dude they got Tapatio and a couple
grams on the table these boys ain't
playing we get the back it says urban
street Japanese Chinese yeah oh they
could be English as a second language
teachers oh he looks like it looks like
Bubba Sparxxx fell on some hard times
oh yeah dude why is he have a black eye
though cuz easy go [ __ ] used to
probably beating people's asses and also
getting hit sometimes while he does it
yeah you're probably right dude yeah
dating single moms odenie single moms
you better come correct bro you better
come correct it really in a single mom
they don't have time to waste and you
know they [ __ ] are they yeah cuz
there's a kid to prove it now that's
true but they got responsibilities don't
waste the times mom she'll have to hire
a babysitter maybe grandma maybe aunt
he's gonna have come by watch the kid so
don't waste time with a single mom all I
know is this somebody told me this valid
deal outside of a
I was outside of a Howard Johnson once
and somebody told me if they'll smoke
they'll poke so that's the thing you
know if you see a lady smoking you know
she's going to do a little bit of dance
with your dad oh really I said I heard
yes Wow and that could hit a rapist tell
you that she smokes she pokes no it was
he on a wheelchair that takes a breath
she down to [ __ ] I guess that's true I
mean the guy obviously just somebody
told him that and that's you know the
create lib by but what are we even
talking about what are these guys doing
single moms okay first of all everybody
King it dude cuz they're single moms are
pretty dope cuz they have to be
responsible okay that means we take care
of you to appoint a kiddo that's uh
they're holding [ __ ] down then only
there's no there's no drama don't have
time to go through your DMS go through
your sock drawer to bring in the backs
of your car find condoms but you got to
be honest with a single mom they don't
come with the [ __ ] that's huh yeah
that's for women with zero chill that's
for zero children whim correct and also
don't come in like I mean I oh let me
see your son when you play catch with
them yeah hold off bro six month waiting
period and I just want waiting pretty
free meet the little man yeah yeah yeah
you know yeah sometimes it you'll try to
meet the kid on the second date there
that's like when we bring a kid to your
father yeah we barely know the mom yeah
get a friend bro yeah for the kid yeah
don't move I like and also a lot of
times with single moms you got a gig
don't show up with a limp wiener no they
like I said come correct and every fast
cuz the I'll tell you this I've spent
some time on a single mom and I was
going through some stuff and this is
right a couple years ago I got I
actually got electrocuted I stepped on a
young cable coming I have a food truck
sure and uh and you don't show up at a
single mom with a limp wiener brother
they don't have time for this [ __ ]
there's no there's already a male in the
house yeah that isn't [ __ ] and that's
their son yes or their deadbeat dad yeah
yeah so you get it all well yeah they
just you don't waste time with them you
can't go park outside of their house and
cry about you know you don't want her
about your problems too many electrons
in your body you know electrolytes
electrons you don't care say yeah King
it gang it shut up the single moms doing
the damn thing oh yeah our second
submission is from Nick Rodriguez
what up Nikki ride in the house coming
out of New Jersey gang gang gang funky
game boom let's go so I got a kid Gator
stinger for y'all cauliflower here am I
getting laid with these bad boys on my
ears or am I getting friendzone cuz I
got [ __ ] chicken nuggets on the side
of my face let me know what y'all think
Gang Gang dude here's both Brandi gets
the tortellinis on this oh yeah you got
that ravioli I do surgeries on this
[ __ ] to do what they do with it nothing
made it worse cuz there's really no
surgeries you can do for oh what are
they trying to do when they do the
surgery i reconstructed well when it was
when you're going through it they try
they slice it open and drain it and seal
back together wax all coming it was a
nightmare the guy didn't know what he's
doing he didn't know where was that here
Denver oh yes a night yeah but uh let
somebody cut through your open in Denver
Brendan showers do that's right dude
that's right Barry Shawshank over here I
need to open up your brain that's what
we need to figure some things out
so we calling from drains your brain it
would just be a [ __ ] smooth yeah yeah
it would be like a peanut butter move
yours yours or yours would be just like
an empty coconut shell just nothing
there yours would be like a fortune
cookie that it's like a little note no
yeah that's damaged that's black from CT
um so with cauliflower yeah let me
another station starter yeah that's a
good point
we'll look shout out Nikki dude out of
Jersey everybody in Jersey is named
Nikki and I [ __ ] love you not
changing the script out there dude um
and uh oh look man if you got the ear
thing going on bro I think it's it looks
kind of heroic a little bit it's kind of
crazy I think no there's these shape
things you can get these like little
shape things people are putting on their
ears now they're well actually like
shape with that shape and into so you
can shape it and like a little no it
doesn't work that way about here you
sound like an elf ear yeah you can't be
on the set of a Hollywood movie Theo no
I'm talking about in real life I think
there's like sell bro we could also wear
earmuffs while you fight you could wear
a mouse you could wear like there's like
there's some real warm ones see or what
are this yeah you're most right your
mouth you know yeah there's some
beautiful when soo that would matches
whatever you're trying to fight in or
you could wear like a helmet or like a
hat that has like long sides on it you
could do all that if you're if he's a
fighter wrestler or whatever depending
what job he goes into aid when you're in
a bar no one's you know [ __ ]
with you it's kind of like saying I know
what the [ __ ] I'm doing don't mess with
this guy right but also it is a badge of
honor I I was a audition for the show
shot the pilot for E my agent called me
when dude good news and bad and it's a
true story good news and bad news I go
alright what's up because bad news
didn't get to show it okay that's
terrible news goes good news is what
they do want to do is put you on botched
and fix your hair no yeah I couldn't do
that's what he said wash [ __ ] dam and
botch botch all those [ __ ] clowns
bros never been [ __ ] dude thinks this
computer button punch and [ __ ] Muppet
know I'll tell you it is do it if you
got ears look cut your [ __ ] ear off
if you don't like it Michelangelo stuff
you New Jersey bra do some Jersey [ __ ]
yeah do it for your girl cut your off
show her your dedication hire a hitman
to shoot your [ __ ] ears off you know
what I'm saying it's New Jersey bruh you
know what I'm saying do whatever you
want staple a [ __ ] a couple
tortellinis a ravioli to the side of
your head have the pigeons bite it off
yeah weird go to new work and just
[ __ ] start yelling racist things and
look cut your ears not for free yeah
sleep with the fishes bro put a little
barbecue sauce and roll into
Philadelphia a couple brothers a bite
your [ __ ] ears right off your [ __ ]
dumb put a pepperoni on and walk in the
streets of New York I think it's a
deep-dish beets oh yeah Rob Kings Prince
King Street pizza baby nobody will think
that is insane New York's insane he is
or do things just come in your head you
come is calm there's come what do you
even know what an idea it depends do I
say soon cauliflower oh yeah you're like
a train station and then every now and
then a Ford Festiva just [ __ ] baby
carriage get on the tracks okay
thanks for hitting us up dude beat
somebody's ass out there Nicky if you
have to or not because your ears should
be good enough
our next submission is from Barry Brady
oh yeah BB 17 years old from Ireland
1700s what is the legal age limit
at 40 got a quick question for you they
welcome to his castle oh [ __ ]
King interesting condoms Gang Gang sting
sting things things thing brother dude
first of all shout out these two dudes
live in a castle bro when I was [ __ ]
17 dude I don't even know Arnie I lived
at my friend's house in a spare room
look at these guys look at the and look
at that they're on the edge of that [ __ ]
I just figured everyone lived in a
castle in Ireland have any roof on it
but still still gangsta yeah how much of
a month is that probably think 600 maybe
there's by a bunch people living there
yeah and also definitely haunted
and there's torture chambers in every
Castle so you gotta take that in their
consideration first of all castles yeah
you look if you the problem with castles
is not a lot of you're not gonna meet a
lot of clean women mmm but you're gonna
meet a lot of cool women but the other
thing is is there's no AC in those big
fights so it gets a little toasty in the
summer yeah cold in the winter yeah that
means everybody you know is gonna be a
petri dish jus that means you're gonna
shake somebody's hand and have a look
[ __ ] good you know measles yeah and
you're yeah you're gonna have a bunch of
uh yeah Black Plague white plague red
plague yeah I mean stop there bro it's
uh yeah it's like a curry restaurant you
can have every type yeah I mean it's
it's insane so that's the problem I
think with castles brah um but also
unless the only person who's living at
castles names Nicolas Cage
yeah and how's that worked out pretty
well he's free to kill in it really all
he possessed Facebook he invested in
Facebook uh I'm sorry face off yeah
totally off he invests in Facebook
create a face I did well the original
Facebook yeah look it up look it up chin
what do you mean look it up do you
let's say you think about it in guest
look it up Nicolas Cage think about some
of great movies he made gone in 60
seconds how you were the best one family
man
oh dude give it up bro so I can touch me
great movie though so good dude why do
you not watch it
I gotta get my life together yeah no you
owe me you watch it it's one of my
favorite movies average up watch your
patting through many times yeah that in
Rudy we bought a house in Jersey we've
got two kids Annie and Josh I love the
Enver about when he goes gets gets the
suit yeah she's a key got your goddamn
mind we're spent $3,000 suit he's like
I'm gonna buy this soon yeah just feels
like the biggest ass everything he says
it's like just so serious God did he or
not chin yeah he's on the board oh there
it is oh wow he was a co-founder well he
went to Harvard - and dropped out with
uh oh wow that's cool um Nicolas Cage
losing cows okay and it worked out for
him yeah but in thinking about castles a
lot of bats
another thing no AC no heat a lot of
bats definitely haunted
torture chambers not a lot of hos trying
to be with no windows you foster
everyone can watch that's true here's
another rule if there's windows there's
hose boy that's a thing right there you
got it today bro if they'll smoke
they'll poke and if there's windows
there's hoes baby I'm gonna say sting in
them sting it our next one is a from
kids wreck kids wreck that's his name-o
kids right Oh Theodore and Brandon I got
a king under stinger for you beatboxing
damn bro Beastie Boy that might be our
new outro kids read butts his name is
Rick his rights and rectum broke ah dude
that's great how many lungs does ya
yeah oh yeah it seemed like he had
asthma like in a trap house bro that's
like the best [ __ ] I've ever [ __ ] her
tomorrow
he was dogs get that silly Nelson vibe
going on brother dude his [ __ ]
straight dress he's the hip-hop [ __ ]
Willie Nelson in oh brother that's this
dude is [ __ ] wigger central and I
love it dude now what happened with him
what did he do he said he's saying King
you're singing it be boxing beat boxing
yeah I probably out of all the skills
that stuff want to make money you know
yeah that's the true there's not really
a circuit for beatboxing I mean usually
if you do it you're in an alley and then
somebody beats you just because you sit
on a box yeah sitting on a box well also
beatboxing originally they put somebody
in a box and it would beat the [ __ ]
box and the sounds people would make let
me put the cat in okay that's a baby
dude okay you a child cat at home that's
your son no that's a cat well and
ironically your son's name tiger so
really we can live together man quit
making your son drink out of a water
dish okay get it together dude you're
standing dad without kids it's weird
look at me judge my panic thing let me
do this person impersonation of a cat
for you I have a limited range of motion
of my neck dude I want to say we're
gonna say that's all right there kids
rec and and we're gonna have to use that
as an inch or an outro sometime that's
[ __ ] outro oh yeah it sounds like
somebody with bronchitis is [ __ ]
bouncing down like a rocky cliff you
know and every time I go they say Erik
but they're like oh it's like a whole
black ball shout out to this guy kid can
do
I don't know how many girls you get
doing that but [ __ ] it dude you don't
need a girl to do that
what need a girl can do you do that
enough you'll [ __ ] see mental flower
out of your body and start dancing they
just play beats a jackoff
yeah maybe don't do that or do and be
awesome what bam bam now if you I'll
tell you this if you [ __ ] you know
you know so decouple jingle bells on
your nuts oh yeah and had that little
try you know that long bone just busting
beads buzz buzz that's it for a king of
the stayin at blowing time to pay the
bills
hey deal you like to make money yeah I
don't mind it dude but it's not all I'm
about but yes I hear you but you could
make money pretty easy user in Robin
Hood
it's an investing app that lets you buy
and sell stocks ETF's options crypto
sits and guess what it's commission free
oh yeah while other brokerage is charged
up to ten dollars for every trade Robin
Hood doesn't charge any Commission fees
so you can trade stocks and keep all of
your profits plus there's no account
minimum deposits needed to get started
so you can start investing at any level
right now the simple intuitive design of
Robin Hood makes investing easy for
newcomers and experts alike so if you
don't know what's going on or you know a
lot about what's going on Robin Hood's
the spot to be super easy to understand
charts market data and place a trade in
just four taps of your smartphone you
can also view stock collections such as
a hundred most popular with Robin Hood
you can learn how to invest in the
market as you build your portfolio so
you can learn as you go discover new
stocks track your favorite companies and
get custom notifications for price
movements so you never missed that right
moment to invest money man my name dolla
dolla dollars Robin Hood is giving you
guys the Kingston listeners a free stock
like Apple Ford sprint to help you build
your portfolio right now sign up at King
sting dot Robin Hood calm that's King
sting dot Robin Hood calm knock knock
who's there an advertisement hey bro did
you like what I was wearing last week uh
honest I got to be honest and I've been
seeing the comments online people are
saying what's going on
I used to be the better-looking one but
last week Theo really upped his game yep
and I thought was it something with his
hair and then it hit me with his shirt
yep you seen that movie Untouchables yes
well Untouchables that's a new movie
that I'm thinking about making because I
had that untuck oh boy hit her I knew it
was the shirt man's willory dude I had
that twittery shirt and it was a
comfortable it was easy to care for it
you look great and it fit perfect yeah
they sent me three of a man three shirts
came in a box I'll put them on Bam Bam
Bam look good every time you know it's
kind of casual especially with summer
coming in it's like there's kind of that
perfect fit and peace if you just want
to ride out and having to have a nice
day yeah and you want to look good the
shipping is always free in the US
there's free returns they got it all man
tailored fit means you always look your
best
slimming where it tucked or untucked
like the freaking king of the sting over
here on tuckable casual shirting cut to
untuck yep and it you can say more when
you bundle get a hundred dollar shirt
for fifty five dollars when you buy in
bulk you mean more than one shirt
anyways you're gonna shirts all the time
yeah people I look I've almost never met
anyone who didn't have a shirt on and
you can't wear the same shirt every day
so might as well get a few of them yep
smart casual just got smarter they got
classic shirting man it's tailored you
look tailored people someone guys like
hey are you tailor and I was like nah
man the shirt is yeah King and the sting
listeners right now I want to let you
know some sweating cuz I'm so excited
about this deal oh dude you can get $25
off your first shirt girl if you go to
your order by going at willory dot-com
/k ats calm down bud oh it's such a good
deal you look so good last week enter
promo code cats at check on its k 80s at
checkout I'm sweating like I'm freaking
why didn't you tell me it looked good
and you know like you could have told me
even personally more look man look I'll
just tell him that if you can't handle
it I don't know King and the sting
listeners can get $25 off their first
short shirt order by go on at will recom
/ k 80s and entering promo code k 80s at
checkout look good support the podcast
next up is debate club
yeah let's get into this [ __ ] dude cuz
you don't know [ __ ] you [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] call your mom to debate me man dude
I need to go to the master who taught
you really I need you're the master dude
you look like you look like a lifeguard
at a tanning salon dude dude you look
like you're in an extra on eastbound and
down like I just give us the wage yeah
I'm gonna keep mine alright that's a
wrap
feel we'll take your way you went now I
like the way I look I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna live life like this hey dude
you got a drop up a couple cases of
Pepsi down the street why don't you
[ __ ] get your dolly bruh get your
hand truck and [ __ ] hit the streets
papa
our first you seemed like that guy what
do you got d our first submission is
from Amanda Frick is there a cat
Amanda [ __ ] what's up white teeth and I
have a debate club topic for you I want
to know if you guys had to spend the
rest of your life with a woman who could
a never laugh or B never orgasm which
would you prefer and I'm talking like no
faking it no giggling nothing like which
which are you go be able to handle I
love you guys Gang Gang buzz buzz what's
up girl buzz buzz every I'll be doing
that I'll show uh use your stupid dude
they need to [ __ ] change his battery
they do it's us no they do we have a
staff of 9700 gas staff of 97 gets paid
a dollar I'm sick of it
[ __ ] sick of it so she was saying a
girl who can't orgasm or she doesn't
laugh mm-hmm
go ahead dude kick it off I would say a
girl who can't orgasm and that's pretty
much most of my ex-girlfriends that's a
little thick and it's not their fault
either
and I'll say [ __ ] a game you know dude I
have a good dick shut up the short game
I just don't have the the agility and
the gamesmanship I think behind my
Weiner isn't now you got that letter I
got that [ __ ] you know I got that big
baby Glen Davis you know what I'm saying
like he comes into the game every now
minute he's a real hitter you know but
then also he's not
fraida you know the time not tail also
fistfight a dude over the counter at a
Hampton Inn yeah when I'm saying it
cause slang and drugs it's like just
makes bad decisions or [ __ ] awesome
decisions but just you know sometimes he
just you know he won the six-man then in
the seventh man award then eighth man
and at a certain point he was just even
like the 700th man award yeah you don't
even on the team yeah but I got uh what
is your girl who can come what is it
think girl who either can't laugh or
girl who can't or gay
I'd say can't orgasm because I think she
can find other fun ways to get that
excitement and energy out of her body do
art maybe do some art some face paint
yeah face paint paint yourself up like a
gorilla you know yeah or a cat that's in
kindergarten or whatever [ __ ] man well
your Tourette's is crazy I would go with
I don't careful girl kit laughs I'm
gonna try my video my girl I don't give
a [ __ ] I don't need her to laughs just
bustin nuts bro busting nuts and shoving
a grand old time
you're disgusting dude I am yeah dude
you gonna marry your the Glenn [ __ ]
what is a big baby
[ __ ] bro yeah that putter for a dick
it's a big deal Oh [ __ ] on that sand
trap style you feel me ally on that
[ __ ] I got that thick whistle yeah
born frog down there dude if you drop my
dick on a sudden it makes this sound
let your tugboat yeah
all right well but here's what I'm
saying that's really important is this
dude please you're a [ __ ] idiot
please say something important okay what
is this lady asking about girl you god
damn it remember the Sun I have second
hand CT you've done nothing CT from the
Sun if CT just from walking outside from
the Sun ever did you shake my hand
pretty hard sometimes I'm saying is this
girl you have to have a woman that can
laugh laughter is important you know
laughter is really orgasm of your soul
you know I'm saying it's just straight
coming out of its science basically
sound calm preach and it's uh if you can
make somebody just shake and make a
noise at the same time that's what
laughter is yeah but also your friends
you know well after an orgasm the same
thing you shake and make a noise alright
fair point
what are you talking about the up top
gasm then that's laughter you talking
about that low gasm then that's you know
uh you know body you know or game what's
that penthouse where doesn't want that
basement gasps yeah right what do you
want I like that penthouse myself do you
yeah up top
yeah I'm going with laughter now just
convince me otherwise
yeah okay well 64% people said never
orgasm mm-hmm cause we're right on the
money huh
makes sense the next submission for
debate club from Quinn Donovan and the
Saigon suck boys Oh thus I got sunk boy
that's Nick first of all that's on Nick
swardson's fantasy football team right
they're very obvious and they're clearly
a was that a cricket game there at
neither the masters or masters or
Kentucky Derby boys you can't dress like
that you dougie damn right you can how
about the boy on the bottom so this hung
up just as Nick Swardson bro let's make
some Burton's a little
little dime sack right there dude what
plate akin what the [ __ ] Club or the
Masters nothing the guy with the camera
has is the whole thing yeah these are
the Saigon suck boys and they're over
there in uh in Marrakech Indiana [ __ ]
- just [ __ ] do it sucked off while
drinking tities just - putting a quarter
in the mouth of a [ __ ] young boy
[ __ ] and Vietnam Malaysia - fricking
pipe him off what did they ask Jesus
these guys are [ __ ] horrible or some
of those comes you can just throw a
penny in the air and some kid will run
and catch it in his mouth and just a
second for dick yeah very very sad so
shout out to third world countries
yeah and second world and also in the
first place the America do it here - oh
you can find that in Hollywood Hills
oh you'll write this street there's a
strip club yeah Kentucky Derby your
masters dude Kentucky [ __ ]
Derby scene the hats and the tits that
Kentucky Derby and the drinks on the
horses I've seen the tits - oh you've
seen the dicks on the horse's gait
horses get your dick out of my face
you've seen those horses big old dinga
dings they got some [ __ ] real wieners
yeah we should look at him up closer my
buddy had a whole stable and we go there
look the real way you could tap a little
stick on you remind me of mr. hands
really who's that yeah you'll find out
but yeah it's [ __ ] Kentucky Derby all
day maths is so boring unless Tigers
playing I've been in the masters man I
was there one time when uh Bobby we're
won it okay and he was Guatemala or
something hey Brittish what were you
doing there working a friend of mine had
guy was there with the buddy of mine I
was working as a tour manager and he's
from Augusta and next thing you know is
that the dang masters dude I'll tell you
this
they got ice cream sandwiches for a
dollar and fifty cents and you can't get
that [ __ ] at a [ __ ] horse race bro
I'm gonna watch people run on some run
if I'm gonna watch someone steroids run
around the track it's gonna be a [ __ ]
attack
dude okay name watching the dang big
horse do it all juiced up I'd rather
watch 12 Italians you'd rather watch
some jackass and thousands hopped up on
some test 600 [ __ ] racer on dirt
right now that'd be amazing yeah where's
that at yeah your boy was called the
Olympics but I heard right but what I'm
saying is this dude I'll go the Masters
all day man you can chill out
everybody's to be real quiet and then
somebody always isn't quiet and just
yells off you know just yell something
crazy you know think of them [ __ ] I
think in a movie [ __ ] happy gilmore
real life everyone's quiet it's all full
of it's a real [ __ ] fest at the Masters
you're the Kentucky Derby it is [ __ ]
good Lord everyone's drinking floppy
hats floppy titties big dick horses
running around you're betting you making
money [ __ ] the Masters Wow
but the Masters you get to watch women
who you probably don't even like that
much fall down when it's a rainy masters
bro and there's nothing better than
nothing better than watching nine chicks
try to go just try to get all the way to
the end of a par four but ninety or
locked huh nine war laws they got some
busted lady gets lucky Derby really ah
man yours you never see it suck it is
that beautiful women yeah all right I'll
give you this one yeah Derby
Kentucky Derby shut up well smart people
well very close so and it was debatable
so good yeah it was a good debate our
next submission uh from lucky Schaefer
that's his name luckily fur from Chicago
what's up guys I hear from the Windy
City Brendan I can't wait to see you
back out here next time bring the Rat
King with you gang a lot back in the
state debate club question though who
would you rather have as a best friend
I'm going old school here Tony Danza of
the Fox okay gang gang dog buzz-buzz
doggie don't start this I'm an easy
you're kind of people I feel like the
phone's got my nerves without yet that
[ __ ] leather jacket yeah the fine
[ __ ] out of here he wants to be the
center of attention
I like Tony dance of that silent [ __ ]
assassin it seems fun good dad always in
a wife-beater always had his house
correct I'm a Tony Danza guy yeah I
probably go dance and I will I'll drop
this joke right now about did you guys
hear what happened to the Fonz is named
Henry Winkler right yeah isn't that show
bear remember he would do a remember hey
you guys hear what happened to the Fonz
he got AIDS that's a joke I used to tell
a long time
that's a Joey to say yeah Wow pretty
good one I mean it's bad if you don't
like you know you don't know it's a joke
it's bets unfortunate aids
yeah and then I'd be like aids uh duh I
said they didn't care anyway what I'm
saying is this man y'all go that I'll go
Tony dance all day the guy was doing
some Fonz's [ __ ] running around with
a mantra in a malt shop father's job
yeah Fonz was just a [ __ ] sexual
harassment waiting to basically he's a
separate on me two things yeah in every
room hey we're the girls that are right
chill bro
she seemed like a guy that had a stroke
right if you learned the vowels you know
totally dance all goddamn day yeah he
seemed like a guy yeah he also created
Alyssa Milano so what's up yeah and she
[ __ ] bothers anybody who has any
[ __ ] human instinct these days on
social media so I wish she would
uncreate her but I'm talking about her
back in the day oh yeah back in the day
now
but now she's gotten pretty verbose I
think well 68% of people went with the
fonts who did who went with the fonts
you need all their [ __ ] names there's
no job people know he's ever did
anything this is kind of guy you wanna
support who shows up on a motorcycle at
a malt store and a leather coat yeah
that's a pedophile white shirt he wore
the same outfit ev'ry show yeah there's
any volunteers and look at his friends
Ralph Malph that guy Tom Petty [ __ ]
you're out of your mind
Harley Davidson [ __ ] [ __ ] out of
your [ __ ] mind boy the next
submission is from Jeffrey Dahmer
Jeffrey Pope alive Jeffrey Pope alive
what's up Theon Brandon its Jeff also
known as the kim jeong-hoon of the
Midwest line what do you think pizza
bagels or pizza rolls let me know what
you guys think doing doing bug bug bug
shadows don't ya row kids shout out to
kim jong indiana whatever that guy's
name is young Chicago yeah he timed his
he had pizza baking in the background
anyway the buzzer hit at the exact
moment Kim Jong deep-dish over there
dude his pizza rolls or pizza bagels
listen man I didn't grow up with a ton
of money and pizza bagels were for the
ballers they got we called him the pizza
Brentwood bagels you didn't [ __ ] with
those pizza rolls now now they were
cheaper but if you're gonna eat those
you need to wait about ten minutes cuz
it's hot lava in the middle no matter
what that thing was filled with
that thing was so hot and I would be so
hungry after school I wouldn't give a
[ __ ] I'll take the third-degree burn
yeah put that pepperoni lava on my mouth
there's no rolls baby oh it's a hate
crime if you eat one of those too soon
and you always and here's a thing with
with the pizza rolls uh it doubts ought
to be frozen right you'll get out of the
oven even after you cook the outside
frozen oh no way this could be out you
put in your mouth and basically it is a
frickin dragon from the seventh layer of
Satan Vil just spewing straight I King
Koopa [ __ ] motor skeet right into
your [ __ ] is that Mario level 3 King
Koopa in your [ __ ] mouth it's
like King Koopa busted in your mouth oh
man II know it's like a firefighter with
a hose full of nut wash just can't just
blast you in at oblivion God but you
still eat them and you still eat them so
[ __ ] pizza rolls baby yeah it should
be a crime there should be a
class-action suit the interior mouth
burn victims should be a felony damn
they're good I'm gonna go with the rolls
64 percent pizza rolls then [ __ ] a
pizza bagel pizza bagels and we heard
that yeah well don't next relationship
advice gang first up from Matthew Gator
no Gator boy Matt here I'm after some
relationship advice I split with my
girlfriend 4 years ago and I still have
thoughts about her yeah she was my first
true love though you ever get over that
or is that just something after par with
thanks for the help in advance Gang Gang
was Beau's brother I like the dog and
that guy for years though Mexico where's
that accent from is he from Texas is
that Texas I think England but close
Thank You Vera is presenting in this is
a good question man years bro I got my
college degree since you've been
thinking about this girl you talking
about bro The Sopranos I start season
one that ended you still thinking about
this girl what the [ __ ] you talking
about move on bro like this girl
dude it's hard to move on when you live
by bees dude that are stinging you I'll
say this young fella I think some of
those you know that's called
ghosts of [ __ ] must pass dude you'll
never forget a girl that you were in
love what they used to make love to she
must have sucked that thing oh dude I
made love to a girl in a river dude or
it was like a stream or something I'll
never ever do you know huh which river
yeah I know exactly what dude Alabama
River you eval you [ __ ] Alabama yes
dude yes I became my Herald thank you I
didn't touch you yeah you did dude now
back to your heart on story about
[ __ ] and Alabama I'll never forget
her and she'll always be a part of my
life no matter every day I think
probably once every two weeks she pops
into my like head like I'll see
something or something will happen and
like oh that reminds me of her so she's
always gonna be a part of your life now
if your part like if you're making paper
mache cutouts of her or in pinatas it
look like her and filling them with
cream and doing you know [ __ ] them
things
well yeah doing nasty with them then
that's different then you gotta tighten
up there but yeah look man I think just
embrace the fact that you guys had some
time together in just hundred years yeah
I wouldn't when you see how in like pine
I would expect oh you know it's so great
that we got to spend time together when
you see her say let's run it back let's
get that master's now that'll happen a
lot now you give giftings time there
will be other time in feature you'd be
able to you'll have chances to date
again do you be amazed how many times
your life center twine or not or she's
like she moved to the states and she's
dating a dude that looks like feelings
gonna break your heart so just move on
and find another girl and start [ __ ]
in streams bro so start [ __ ] in
streams even ponds lakes the Cherry
Creek Reservoir and Danner or just fill
a cup up with water and put in your bin
[ __ ] that works too but yeah just be
well good luck my man yeah be willing to
do something good for yourself man
you're not dating Adam just starts lying
in bro yeah just start juggernut in
[ __ ] yeah fine chicks I like
honeybraun invited him over to the
Beehive baby yes start B boxing and
slang and dick punched up next we got
shaitan hall from Asheville North
Carolina shooting to myself before hey
Brendon hey Theo gang gang buzz-buzz
today's for a relationship advice and I
am just wondering like Jim the girl for
about a year and a half now about a
moving to college
and I'm not interested in moving into
the same College with her in the same
relationship with hell no I want to go
in fresh yes so a lot of people been
telling me to break up with her before
yes just wanted to get your guy's
opinion on it what do you think hope you
guys have a great one
love your guys's content get your shows
in North Carolina
seriously either one of you have a great
one boys to shake cheers she here's the
thing bro what is the thing here he
knows the answer he's like I want a
fresh start when good dude
let me tell you something me go when you
go to colleges why did I go are never
been there so yeah we're at home school
there's not that many people to choose
from but when you hit that whatever they
let us dress up like college kids once a
week well that works but when you get to
that college campus it is utopia for
[ __ ] you don't want old saddlebags
back in the old school town yeah no dude
start you want a fresh start you don't
want those strings attached yeah bro and
then here's the thing when you get back
for a summer you guys can still hang out
yeah but while you're on campus you're a
free man dude you're a free man i'ma
start watch Amistad pop some acid maybe
a little Molly just start [ __ ] each
other
that's college amigo that is a crime and
what I'm talking about is Amistad you
need to go watch a movie called Amistad
dude it's about a young man that finally
gets his freedom and learns what it's
like to be free oh no Shawshank
Redemption you'd watch that too well so
soon divison it's more of like a prison
it sounds like I'm Asada's like about I
guess it's I don't know what's like
about boat travel or something but what
I'm saying is this brother is that you
the problem is you have to let her know
this it sound like you know what's up do
you know what's up might even let her
know in a really I would the best thing
cuz I I went back in time if I went back
in time here's what I did I broke up
with my girlfriend and then I regretted
it and then I just bothered her on the
phone like five or six times a day I
would call her and I would cry sometimes
on her answering machine and then she
ended up [ __ ] some guy in a parking
lot so for you what you got to do is ya
broke kid's heart to your chin chin is
to it oh yeah that happened to chicken
Oh bro well that's I mean basically it's
live baby
a lot of dances of wolves in Vietnam
right there yeah you know so I'm gonna
say this to you whoever you are young
man do you young bro you could die and
probably come back to life that's up
[ __ ] young you are right six lives
yeah do you can go to jail for murder
please second uh manslaughter in the
second degree probably get eight years
double jeopardy yeah be out you could
have killed somebody you don't like and
still not even be thirty yet you got
time
here's something you can do for yourself
bucko that might help is just be loving
the way you present it to our look I
love you this what's going on it's gonna
be really really tough to deal with how
can we what can I do to help you deal
with this best you know because she's
not gonna be [ __ ] stoked about it
dude or she is cuz she's like you know
I'm going usually of Alabama I'm about
to let these crimps and I slam on a
train on me yeah yeah we should probably
break up yeah we should probably break
up to get that dick saving you feel me
baby that light saving oh yeah that
[ __ ] bent Richardson yeah yeah kill
me
so here's what I'm saying dude that
[ __ ] dark Ingraham brave about to
meet some real brothers over there so
let's say this young lass or what's his
name shhh Satan say no like Seton Hall
nobody cool so yeah manly you got it bud
but I think you know you could also say
let's meet up every month and spend time
together I'm saying like nah not every
month every summer maybe fall break
spring break no it's not he's already
like dude I'm gonna get them kind of do
my own thing what should I do fellas
oh yeah he's already yeah well what the
[ __ ] so maybe maybe for those four years
just slangs much dick and do as much
drugs as possible now much dick he even
has does he have a dick do we even know
what his life is like his name Shaitan
Hall hell yeah is a fat custard so dude
slang that dick in college do all the
drugs you want get your education and
then when you come back you can recoup
you know and see maybe if there's
something there
look how get your education is
Pregnant's fourth thing to do it at
college coming believable yeah Rendon
showers over here Brendan two rivers saw
over here guys knows two rivers insider
[ __ ] in the Mississippi River and you
think you got your master's degree it's
the Alabama River you free either
or bro all right next up and rip my
drift the first one coming from adam AKA
el diablo from Topeka Kansas and how his
Adam's Pelt is at 80 om RA da m ad am oh
damn
don't break my Achy Breaky [ __ ] hard
on him Chan what are you doing Jimin out
we just guess what he looks like from
far away oh wow beat him he's in he's in
uh okay I'm not mad at that denim top
now I was taught agree that jackets been
signed by someone can you zoom in on
that signature please oh that looks like
Kenny Chesney it looks like Kenny
Chesney that's a Kenny Chesney signature
and those are some Michael Jordan Hanes
with a [ __ ] little Adam El Diablo
[ __ ] hanging out the front oh yeah this
guy Oh
swaggy coconut oh damn that's that
[ __ ] download meta it's uploading
that soft that [ __ ] uploading that
software brother I like it that's the
devil's dandruff on that iPhone here
dude I'll pray let me [ __ ] I'll get
from here oh boy dude I'll [ __ ] do
that [ __ ] from here dude I'll [ __ ]
balance that [ __ ] on your nuts and do it
yeah brode [ __ ] dear me some coca
hina baby oh dude I'll [ __ ] balance
that [ __ ] on a [ __ ] kickball and do
it right I don't give a [ __ ] son dude
this guy looks like he you know he looks
like he's gonna snort all that Coke and
do all his laundry though yeah that's it
that's what that's what's going on here
yeah this guy's in a lot he's gonna get
a little high little drunk and do a
shitload of laundry yes it personally
isn't a laundry mat he's in his
underpants suds and dogs baby oh yeah
dude he looks like uh he looks like um
yeah bro oh I was just think of
something you never have no idea
looks like you know what the promise you
don't I know you're a drug addict cuz
you're zoning off staring at that
[ __ ] cocaine like a psycho
it looks like I was making sure nobody
was taking it
bro you were drooling you know what I'm
gonna report this to your Pio officer
yeah and I don't think you should be
around these drugs or this dick this is
your [ __ ] show you robbed me and
you're the one putting this in front of
me I didn't put this in Friday so Nelson
like did this well first of all this guy
done out Jason Aldean yeah Jason all me
[ __ ] laundrymat doing cocaina wash
the [ __ ] out of a white tee though all
honesty Oh bro looks like he's chasing
all dope bro this dude is obviously
trying to get high as [ __ ] dude he's got
some too he's got a cigar is a hat on a
miller lite badge
she's got [ __ ] bro does he [ __ ] yeah
okay 1997 Johnson or outside of one
who's he [ __ ] they like at this level
you're [ __ ] he looks like yeah slim
jims in his pocket he looks like they've
gotta have slim jims yeah it looks like
he definitely does slim jim the
suppositories a little capsules yeah bro
that teriyaki brush oh yeah yeah brother
and what's his problem chin yeah what is
he sick oh listen doing laundry is a
bummer I like his attitude I like that
he has drugs there I like that he
dressed up for it I like there's alcohol
there I like that his cell phones there
so he's [ __ ] do a line and read the
comments he's doing law need to hate
they call it doing laundry bro and I
like it yeah shut word shout to [ __ ]
uh Jason Aldean for sending one in
though yeah shuttle to Garth cooks his
brain cells our own the Beast thing man
bring a shot oh my god what is this bro
sakes uh you know bro going down a
Saturday night tells O'Hare to eros
Philippines to an Aerosmith concert bro
got a problem with it on whatever spent
this week in Vegas
are you yeah
do you like yeah Chen la Souris
Chien you like yo Smith you want free
tickets because they're back on tour and
it's do that 19 feel he started bragging
oh dude I got tasty dosa through it cool
because it's not 1992 you think you're
gonna be old man yeah yeah you know
you're batshit crazy if you think they
sound anything like they you saw come on
really
hey they're gonna be awesome bro Jenny's
got a feel like we're better than they
are
yeah but that's why I dressed up like
that I was a I saw the veins in your
neck
cuz I'm Aerosmith thing you [ __ ] oh wow
yeah won't you pipe up a [ __ ] couple
of grams your area on a [ __ ] gram day
and get the [ __ ] out of here I'll go to
that concert I listen to real music you
never ever brag they're going to eros
dude I got taste it
[ __ ] yeah bro did it come with a [ __ ]
hot tub time Michigan in 1997 you can
watch mrs. Doubtfire afterwards I see
what you're doing here you're trying to
distract us from the fact that you're a
crossdresser you [ __ ] creepy bro I'm
trying to hang out with the boys that's
not it
that's it oh we hit it bro it isn't it
like all notes mm-hmm oh and smoke if I
could see it I could do it I don't know
that one either yeah bro you look like
that was our Kelly [ __ ] idiot really
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] you're not gonna see
that at the concert bro that's why you
bought tickets you thought you didn't
see I believe I can fly and it was like
I can't wait bro we should bring our
[ __ ] Space Jam jerseys
you [ __ ] morons dude first of all
anyway I'm a hot [ __ ] chick dude dude
looks like a lady I look like [ __ ]
mrs. Doubtfire she did all the D ball
you look like brandy snap shot off a
[ __ ] Instagram bar you look [ __ ]
horrible
you look like enough McCaig and you look
like a shitty drummer for [ __ ] Motley
Crue do you look at your my Watkins as
if I can look like I hear people are
starting to call the blonde Adam ray
just like Jer what they call ultimate
power bottom baby look like Lisa can't
draw that's it you look like in this bro
I was like friends if they made a
transvestite fortune of it yeah he look
like
Frank's bro a bunch of ladies trying to
hide their [ __ ] [ __ ] in their dress
all right let's uh let's let's a finance
woman we got we got one more rip my drip
and it's McKenna me Morris 25 you get my
face off this thing cream Lord oh Lord
I'm sweating James II got the meaty
fronts Mackenzie got them one two Koppel
gobblers out the front
Cadbury eggs hell yeah man she looks
like a classy lady
due to my fishing right now because I
see a motorboat in the future you feel
me tacklebox Benny Benny can you box
Benny and some nice tips there's some
nice to it I'm staring at my ugly ask
them some nice as it is almost say this
after being trapped in a room with seven
men for no [ __ ] fest in here and after
you thinking that Aris mr. with our
Kelly this is a nice you know this is a
fresca she's a nice fresca yep yep and
she's got a nice necklace she has our
arms look nice she okay my oh so you can
look both directions look at each
picture she's looking a different girl
yeah pretty cool right comes done well I
like the fit I like the outfit yep you
can see she cares about ourselves she
really takes care of or something that's
McKenzie Morris when she is all natural
because some things are real real nice
babe can you tell us a little bit about
her please she didn't send much she sent
this picture okay well then killing it
though it has a lot outfits in the back
it appears a lot of choices what's a
trip ripped apparently I wish they
didn't give you recess at school
really I wish they'd I need a break next
thank you can't a good kids this way
should stay in school see what happens
we play kickball - you're 34 dude yinz
clean school see what happens we play
freeze tag with your mom growing up what
else you got mixed up with the flow of
my aunt
the first aunt is auntie Virginia honey
Virginia a hundred years old
lives in a retirement home she's fully
sane but she speaks her mind and she
can't hear very well
Oh sounds like my dream hmm be taken
care of every day live in a place get to
play board games unlimited dessert bunch
of friends low-sodium meals
bunch of pills oh yeah they just toss
you in the pool with your friends yeah
they change you every day [ __ ] your
pants whenever you want
well no you can't I wouldn't you could
don not change it you don't no one cares
okay any [ __ ] her pants they cool so did
the rest of us people here on the pool
bro every time I Drive by an old folks
home I say oh man I really don't think
to myself I care about those people
really i honk my horn and laugh
oh yeah because they're doing well cuz
I'm like damn that's gonna be me one day
and I hope it's me that's not why you
know it's me and you in there together
bro
I don't wear like grumpy old hey hey hey
don't touch me bro hey it's still gonna
look exactly the same
I know you know this though right you
know this you're gonna be the ugliest
older man we've ever seen you think oh
my god but that knows what's wrong nose
your ears are just gonna grow and you're
just gonna [ __ ] look like the bad guy
I was like [ __ ] like the bad guys off
Smurfs senior citizens Virginia though
bro yeah but dude your brain condition
is gonna get so much worse than you
doesn't matter you [ __ ] your pants they
feed me and push me in the pool I'm
talking about the next two years though
I'm fine bro yeah that's what they all
say dude I know what L say these people
die all the time all your [ __ ] you
still ask for letters dad recess Roger
Laster man do you um Kobe where all
these [ __ ] died dude you're
gonna I'm fine dude you don't ask him
for a Hall Pass as a grown man just go
to the bathroom yeah Derek doesn't have
any hall passes dusty roads all you
[ __ ] died dude you're dead I'm
dead
yeah dude you're dead inside already
no I'm gay anymore eleven sign Oh Oh bro
brah rot nope no worms here boy up next
we got grandma Mamaw honey well show us
that broad oh yeah oh [ __ ]
in her 90s her favorite thing to do is
the dishes and she's wrong racist the
favorite things used the dishes and
she's a LSU fan and listen chill out on
the crosses behind you lady first of all
she's looking for the Lord she got that
real yeah I think she found him I miss
you got a lot of cross hurry in the back
but is too many you when you have that
many crosses and LSU blanket in your age
and her favorite thing to do the dishes
you don't think she drops the n-word
every Tuesday like it's [ __ ] happy
hour
as soon as five o'clock hits Oh n-word
time yeah but if your senior citizen I
think you can kind of use anywhere from
5 to 7 p.m.
5 to 7 yeah that's fair yeah wait for
the Sun to go down yeah and you can't do
it on your porch yeah no it's an indoor
word these days yeah
so I think but also she's LSU Tiger fan
you got to respect that and they should
have a section at algae games for people
use the n-word they just have to sit at
the intersection
you can only drop the n-word at halftime
in overtime yeah what do you think
Derrick I love it you know what I mean
right goes with the band all the races
people yeah just to get it out just to
get it's like yeah just it's like the
purge oh yeah they should have an
exorcist when people say the n-word and
it's like they show up and just get it
out of ya like that gay guy who's like I
don't like men of Nyx
third ah we got aunt jane mulligan on
jane she know mr. [ __ ] steel yeah she
uh she works at Home Depot in the
gardening department [ __ ] she loves
to make candles and décor soap as a
hobby Oh beautiful I love so makin she's
varying the dirt bike right racing and
she breathed Yorkshire Terriers she
works at Dome Depot bro she got that
headpiece do you know I get a headband
contest with this auntie so you don't
want to drive by and see her on that
Excitebike and a [ __ ] turtleneck oh
that is so gangster we it's hard to rock
that's our turn like I used to work at
Outback Steakhouse actually I got a job
there and then I got laid off cuz a
woman who looked just like this lady
complain Mulligan no she complained I
was using a fake ID to work there
Oh what is it it was run a [ __ ] it was
like so we worked obits right you got a
turtleneck on you had that [ __ ]
standard great clips cut like let me do
my thing and she ended up being a cop
she didn't care about the damn blues I
did and I needed that job
to be dopest an of all time though she
does dirt bike racing and [ __ ] starts
oh yeah gardens and [ __ ] yeah she's in
the dirt man she's either riding on her
or she's planting in it oh she knew 360
backflips you know what they call her
Mississippi mud charred baby she's a
mudskipper
oh yes and that's not a racist term do I
don't don't I know it isn't I know what
they all are yeah I Mississippi
mudskipper yeah as a natural type of
lizard yeah I don't do it I don't I've
never said that dude and I've definitely
been rough mudskipper that it's a real
lizard
don't get me weird that's a whatever you
say guy you seem pretty racist right now
okay I'm just one be clear though you
have a claim yeah clear that you're
racist dude told you that huh that's an
animal look it up on Poundstone huh
Michael Rizzi there it is bro right
mudskipper baby get them dsls on it okay
look exactly the same exactly the same
case same eyes bro same nose same lips
road you get a both like bikes would you
get a [ __ ] from a fish if it took its
teeth out it feels like a grouper like a
big grouper and I was in the water like
the Mississippi yeah or like a catfish I
always thought about this like you know
people just stick to hands and deep
throat catfish yeah yeah
figure it out bro oh I feel you I'm sure
somebody's figured that out oh they are
there's another animal right there she
said animal hey look I can cool and
you're welcome Jane Mulligan first of
all uh shout out to the mudskipper yeah
shout out to Jane Mulligan Aunt Jane she
seems like someone put a turtleneck on
that mudskipper for me
she makes me give you fair change if she
worked at a convenience store and you
went in and paid for something yeah I
like her and I respect that shout out to
her turtleneck shout to hear this
episode without it dude good [ __ ]
brother yeah well you coming up from the
west palm coming up love west palm the
end of April pretty excited about that
I'm going to eros and then I'm one of
the Dustin Poirier fight this weekend
UFC fans I beg you don't beat up the
okay this haircut he's a good dude and
it's his first fight yeah what do I wear
I don't know to where we're just nothing
just wear your underwear like were my
king in the Singh Jersey Oh do it no not
at all
people rand-new I never even put it on
yeah dog good luck at the fight should
be with our boy Rogan yeah that's gonna
be fun
Errol Smith have fun I will report back
report back and pick me up at or t-shirt
that well they're going to pick me up a
shirt I appreciate that XL thanks I'll
let your boy okay into this month I'm in
Phoenix and up live you were just there
so I'm at set up live 26 27th this month
and then I'm off to Tampa next month
Tampa Bay improv baby gang improv in
Cleveland t5k calm for tickets yeah
Thank You Derrick potion for being here
with us today helping us out
I'm sorry for anything Theo said that
offended you I'm sorry for anything you
said that offended everyone and I'm I'm
just sorry did the viewers appreciate
you brother Gigi - may I take your son
to the vet